and I thought he might have traveled
twice
and a foul down the other end James and
Gordon getting into it
the officials trying to get between them
[Applause]
James doesn't usually react like that
Gordon also upset
and D'Angelo Russell taking practice
threes as the Skirmish happens he has no
desire to get in the parade
[Applause]
so the officials will take a look at
this
[Applause]
it's clear James got took a shot in the
chin but it seemed inadvertent took
exception to it but he took exception to
the fact that Aaron Gordon would not
allow his arm to be released
I didn't think Aaron Gordon did anything
wrong
LeBron is saying right now he's not
allowing him to take his arm away
[Applause]
so double technical
I got no problem either way I think this
is just playoff basketball absolutely I
welcome it this kind of stuff that you
see on a lot of possessions
there's the inadvertent smack in the
face and he has 23 points and you're
Aaron Gordon you
you gotta up your level of physicality